restaurant workers have always been
there for us they've worked long hours
they've worked late nights they've
worked holidays away from their families
all to make sure that we're happy and
fed now it's time to repay the favor
because of the kovat 19 pandemic
millions of restaurant workers have
either lost their jobs or had their
hours drastically cut and his dining
rooms across the country shudder takeout
and delivery of the last remaining
lifelines from many beloved restaurants
so here's our challenge to you yes you
the one in front of a screen with the
hair and the shirt lucky bastard if you
can afford it order more food than you
can eaten one meal from your favorite
restaurant but those leftovers in the
fridge and make the most creative dish
possible with them the next day
take a picture post it to social media
with hash tag leftovers challenge and
urge your followers to do the same we've
all gathered together to cook with
leftovers from our favorite restaurants
to give you a few ideas and click that
donate button to give directly to the
restaurant workers Community Foundation
your money will go towards direct worker
relief nonprofits supporting the
restaurant industry and zero interest
loans for restaurants to start back up
again why are we still here let's cook
something yeah
[Music]
alright sup guys did what balgan I'm
really sorry before we get started here
just your audio is really bad
all the sudden was anything else hearing
that your audio is really bad shut up
hold on and for whoever's editing this
I'm gonna do a clap for sake damn it
stop showing off man I'm glad you guys
got me a part of this challenge man this
is uh something I do on a regular basis
anyway yeah just took a out of leftovers
and so you know I figured why not do a
burger cause it's bringing us all
together anyway especially during this
time I have leftovers from this place
coffee beans teriyaki which is like my
neighborhood toy I got their
world-famous teriyaki sauce what makes
it so famous if I might ask
it's probably the amount of sugar in it
because it's crap dude it's super sweet
and it's savory
every time I order I order like eight or
nine extra and you cannot throw away you
cannot throw away the sauces that you
get from mama pop join that is like rule
number one never it's very bad one any
good that's worth its weight as amazing
mac salad
dude mac salads a way of life you get
the mac salad the yaki sauce the full
white rice you mix it all together it
just makes sense
I feel like it's a super white
Midwestern like white trash potluck dish
that somehow was like traveled the globe
and like other people made it like even
decorous incredible thing I've never
heard of this before
yeah teriyaki joints are totally a West
Coast thing from Seattle to Portland to
Southern California it's like it's the
neighborhood joint so I have to put it
on I have to shine for my people at
evenings I'm gonna be really upset that
I'm not gonna be able to try this when
you're finished with it yes you have the
burger towards the screen and I'll eat
like a six day old banana or something
that's like it like these sweet goodness
well let's show you how to make this
burger yeah I got like old steamed rice
to cut through all the sweetness in like
the richness of the maxout and the sauce
they have is pickled cabbage
no no no jazz that up as you can see we
don't have any funds so that's I'm going
to use the rice oh yes oh yeah so I'm
moving up the cast-iron a little bit Wow
I'm thinking about the father's office
burger right it's unlike an oblong kind
of roll and I don't even know if I like
call it a burger at that point like what
point are you still allowed to call it a
burger ah that's a touchy subject right
like my Boy George books he always says
that converter is two things bread and
chopped meat so I'm completely going out
of left field there's no bread here so
this is more of like a loco moco
inspired I don't know as long as you can
like clutch it and shove in your face
it's like the Great Depression recipes
there's another like mock apple pie
we're still using apples they just use
Ritz crackers like this is some grandma
you know this is some like okay that's
one patty you like a thicker patty this
is about I take five ounces but I'm
still gonna give it a little bit of a
smash yeah what is that device chiselers
down so it's like Oh what of course the
answer is though but it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
tonight it's it's smashing burgers what
do you what do you Bradley Oni over
there we put I've got some of this
pickled cabbage right here and I'm gonna
like westcoast it up mixing it with a
little bit of secret sauce which is
really just mayo mustard and ketchup
yeah big three grits out man
yeah so I got that the biggest teriyaki
sauce in the game man I love that I'm
telling you so yeah this is the bottom
pet the bottom one Jay's reached in like
I can touch it goddamn I'm gonna throw
on this tsukamoto special socks
throw the burger on top of that oh yes
sir yeah it's like Max salad in time
this is like a place like a lasagna it's
like a parfait yeah well I got a little
special treat - towards the end well the
back so it's going on top and I'm
serving side no no this is this is
definitely another burger taboos it's a
night report burger I don't really have
a top bun yet it's already two feet tall
I love this so much
hey ed look for ya smash it down what
else you got your sleeve so what's this
also make Japanese curry oh yes oh you
bad man you could try to eat this with
your hands if you try real hard I think
you should frankly man whoa calling this
yeah the wu-tang killer beads
damn it's a mouthful literally both its
name and its form factor and it sure
ain't nothing to [ __ ] with spoon eat
this burger with a spoon dude dude oh
not the Filipino spoon now the crispy
rice the sauce that's mixed with the
tsukamoto is coming through all the
richness okay maybe this is it a bird
call you out hell yeah I don't wait to
watch you do that because I want fried
egg on top yes that blush is still hot
throw an egg on there yeah that's it so
that's an act
there we go now it's complete yeah crack
that yokel on me baby yeah let's get
some runny Wow I have me - yeah thanks
dick I might try to recreate this in my
house dude it looks too good it's
delicious
hopefully this is
fires people to cook with their
leftovers hashtag leftover challenge
yeah man dude like I'm glad you guys
invited me to be a part of this you know
restaurant workers are very important to
me obviously they're like my lifes mind
me they helped my career out 100%
support restaurant workers and I've also
created my own dish babish to cooking
with leftovers we got Joshua Wyson
involved we also got internet Shaquille
so check out the videos from all of us
we're all in on the same challenge
trying to accomplish the same thing
thanks for having me guys thanks for
having us in your kitchen that hopefully
I get to see you guys see you climb that
current stay home peace out y'all guys
Elvan hey you know it's a good-looking
burger I'm sure it tastes great
technically it's not a burger I mean the
definition of a burger is it has to be a
beef patty cooked somehow and then it's
served on bread not rice that's like a
burger plate to her burger or science
project